Putin gives a speech and
you know he's talking to the the I mean
you'll see when he's going through it
but he gives a speech about the family
nucleus and how America is making a big
mistake right now and what's causing a
fall and then we'll get some reaction
here from everybody go ahead and play
the clip if you can okay
he's just a bit
um
go back turn off the audio I'll read it
on what he's saying so go back and turn
off the audio and put it on 1.5 speed
I'll read it at a fast pace if you want
to press play I have one request what's
that please read it in a Russian accent
hello yeah we're not we're not doing
that yeah I already have an accent let
alone the Russian I mean I can do it
press play and here they lie constantly
perverts historical facts do not stop
attacks on our culture
the Russian Orthodox church and other
traditional religious organizations of
our country
see what they do with their own peoples
the destruction of the family cultural
national identity
children and pedophilia are declared the
norm he's talking about America
pedophilia is the norm the norm of their
life and Priests are forced to bless
same-sex marriages
interesting
god with them let them do what they want
to do what do I want to say here adults
have the right to live as they want we
have always thought like this in Russia
we always will
no one will invade private life we are
not going to do this
so far sounds reasonable but I want to
tell them look at the holy scriptures
the main books of all other religious
world religions everything is said there
including that the family is the union
of a man and a woman
so they're clapping right now in the
audience great hat yeah
but these sacred texts are now in doubt
as it became known the end angle um
Anglican Church for example plans to
consider the idea of gender neutral God
oh my God what can we say forgive us
Lord they do not know what they do wow
everybody clap clap
millions of people in the west
understand that they are leading to a
real spiritual disaster
the elites directly I must say go crazy
and it seems that they can no longer be
treated
but these are their problems as I said
and we must protect our children
and we will do this protect our children
from degradation and degeneration and
the speech is over with so what are your
thoughts about that speech that he gives
okay what do you think about it okay so
now
Tom uh Adam I'll go to you first you
hear a speech like that he's given Putin
the commentary is 50 50. we just want to
prepare you the commentary is 50 50.
what do you think when you hear him give
a speech like that about America uh I
think if any leader made a speech like
that we would all kind of be like oh
yeah like let's return to normal and
let's just you know respect religion and
you know probably we're not going to
invade your private lives I think when a
thug like Putin gives that speech you
automatically are like okay if you
disagree you'll die so uh
again a lot of what he said makes sense
and by the way show of hands if you're
like a fan of Putin in this room
okay so it's not like we have a okay we
have a couple and just why are you a fan
of Putin a fan
you like Putin I get what a fan is but
why are you a fan
you like Russian history okay you're
like the Russian history and are you a
capitalist yourself are you pro-america
or no
you name your boy after Stalin your son
can we get the KGB in here
by the way you're being serious are you
you're a trolling right now straight up
you know what I love about this here's
what I love how long you've been
following our content
20 2015 2016 you've been following the
content okay so why do you like Putin
uh just what I read about history like
Russia yeah so I read about all of his
like Russia like Lenin Stalin
what are your thoughts on Lenin and
Stalin fan
well I read their books I read all of
them so you're a fan I'm a fan I read
all history I liked history I liked
America history I like I've read
mineconf about Adolf Hitler but I'm not
a fan yeah I read man Club too nice are
you a fan no I'm not a fan already okay
got it all right well you're a fan of
Putin I like Russian German history
every history really history history
okay how do you view Putin as an
individual like how he's doing as a
leader of his country and then who he is
to US America is he a pro West is he a
fan of what we're doing or is he a enemy
to state number one well if we have to
go to war with them I would like if it
was between us and Them put it that way
meaning what you you would yeah I would
say I have to fight them okay
interesting yeah we're already going
with that Adam what was your point well
I just wanted to get to read the room
because there seems to be this like
fascination with Putin and you can have
respect for somebody and even what they
stand for but at the same time
understand that he's a bad dude he he
wants to bring down America he wants to
bring down the West he's not uh on Team
America whatsoever uh and I think part
of our country right now is that whether
you're on team red or team blue just
remember you should be on team red white
and blue and I think that's just
something that you know who who'd we
have on the other day was it Jimmy Dore
that was talking about what Tucker
Carlson is saying about uh Putin I don't
remember if it was him or not but uh Tom
what do you think about this so I
believe that that is a political speech
and he was preaching to the choir that
was there that was his military
industrial front line there in the first
two rows Medina Dev you can see him
sitting right there
and so I number one I think he's
trolling us a little bit but number one
I think he's trolling us with the
reflective truth of one side because I
think he's trying to divide
but I'll have to tell you if I close my
eyes I didn't know who was speaking and
I heard that
um there's a lot of Truth in it and
there's a lot of stuff in that that I'm
like yeah that's correct yeah that's
true this is what we are doing to a
generation of children so I see that
part of it but then I say okay why is
this guy saying it and saying it now and
saying it this way I think he's trolling
and CR trying to create political
division Among Us I I agree and it's
like right that's like you said he's
rallying the troops back because with
everything that's happening right now
he's just reaffirming to all of them
where where he stands and where they are
as a as a nation
that's it that's it
okay I think he believes yeah and I
think there's parts of it that he
absolutely believes but I think he's
trolling so let me ask you what is the
likelihood in the next 20 years that a
president from the right or the left or
the middle tells that speech in his own
or her own way
would it be more from the left or right
or the middle
oh it's coming from the right oh yeah a
speech like that will come from the
right order in the U.S you mean here in
the U.S U.S leader yep so so maybe so
what is the right uh turned on by that
speech like what did he say did he say
low taxes did he say pro-military did he
what did he talk about pro-marriage he
talked Family Values he talked uh uh God
he talked leave our kids alone and
parents resonate with that story it
would be great if an American president
gave a message like that to protect
parents to say leave our kids to hell
alone that's it and by the way
I'm willing to tell you I'm willing to
tell you if that present that
presidential candidate is left right or
Center we would all applaud for that
person it doesn't matter but somehow
some way a basic message like that
doesn't come from the left period and
what's going to happen is you're going
to piss off moms who are sitting there
saying dude listen man you can do
whatever you want to me go for it you
cross the line when you mess with my
baby you're going to see a different
side of me you ever seen like my wife if
you ever talk to her I didn't think she
was naturally like this nice all the
time she's like this all the time by the
way I thought it was like an act like
I'm like you can't be like this all the
time there's got to be an act so so you
know when you date you get into some
fights and you're like you see a
different side and I've seen some sides
I'm like okay cool there you go so you
know the the breaking point you do
something to any of our kids
Jen goes from straight up playing with
her hair like this look what she's doing
right now playing with her hair she goes
from that to straight up like gangster
coming out you know a whole different
person shows up she's ready to you know
throw down but that's what's happening
to moms moms are resonating with a
message like this if a strategist is
there seeing a video like this I tweeted
I don't know how many millions of views
of God just listed I got like 40 30 000
like seven thousand retweets
hey candidates this is an important
message for American people you may want
to consider realizing how important this
is to people go yeah the message will
not will fall upon deaf ears because it
is Putin giving the speech and
everyone's like okay buddy keep it
moving but let's just let's just go back
three to six months there was the newly
elected Italian Prime Minister what's
her name again Georgia Maloney she gave
a very similar speech and it was it was
it went worldwide and I think that's
what I think you're you're I mean that's
kind of where Jen was going parents are
just saying yeah leave us alone let us
raise our kids and there's nothing wrong
with that when it comes from Putin I
don't know about all that so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]